okay mimi is eating something she's not
supposed to be eating
sorry about that
so robin what brought you um to the isle
of goldendoodle's facebook page
obviously we love golden doodles so when
i found the group on facebook
it was natural and to finally find that
community it was it was so special
something special
this is pippa this is my doodle this is
mimi
and this is muppet so cute you've had
muppet for a little while now how old is
he
muppet is five years old and mimi's the
newest
member to the bunch so cute mimi is six
months she's this months old
what made you want to add a second
golden doodle muppet's been a big part
of our lives
whenever we have a bad day whenever
things get a little rough he's always
there
but occasionally he can get a little
anxious if he's left alone
or if he's separated from us so to
counter that
we got mimi to help him out because he's
been helping us out so much
do the dogs know any cool tricks
mimi doesn't you know many tricks yet
yeah muppet can shake hands uh he's just
he's really well tempered hippo also
does jump
which you can teach them to do if you
just literally hold it like kind
of behind them pippa jump up good girl
good girl can you jump
jump
jump you're doing a very good job oh
maybe just kind of fell down that only i
saw you shake hands
are there any other dogs that you get
them together for playdates with
my brother has a long hair dalmatian
in lando and they get along really well
the other dogs that he's met are zach
levine's mastiffs he's met them before
they're really sweet dogs really sweet
pups obviously you're a twin
how are your dogs able to discern you
from brook
do you think they know the difference i
haven't noticed too much confusion
perhaps a little apprehension
they know they really he realized it's
not me he realized that that's not robin
that's not my dad but he was he was
thinking
what's going on are you trying to pull a
fast one on me
if we ever need to get rid of brooke
i've got a twin right here anyway that's
much much preferable his muppets
favorite toy is lamb chop
and i find that's the favorite toy of a
lot of dogs a lot of doodles i'm not
sure what it is
but they all seem to love the lamb chop
toy
i'll have to get pippa that toy it was
so
cool to see you in the i love
goldendoodle's facebook group but i
really hope that you continue to share
pictures of muppet and
uh mimi especially as she gets bigger
and i'm so glad that we were able to
meet you guys yeah
same here i'm gonna keep looking for
pippa i think uh muppet and mimi kind of
have a puppy pen pal now
[Music]